hi sorry i was i was caressing your face
loving me Collin I like me to you on
kind of funny com I wish I had a partner
you will eventually next car people come
back I'm sorry I'll be right back what's
wrong you guys hang tight who is this
guy I'm gonna daily from us nice are you
stealing from my son Kevin Kevin arts of
silicon valley recreation the man who
feels no that's my water here's your
water demon I have so many waters up
here I want you guys to know also that I
pics this patio furniture it's all that
we're on top of its awesome awesome but
it's good but there's two drawbacks to
it that we'll have to figure out for
next year if they invite us back which
is be honest they will not know no one
wanted or yes why they're probably [ __ ]
Hanuman show up to this number one
they're very slippery and I think their
design that way because our outdoor
furniture right there like you pour rain
all over that's true number two because
they're slippery they don't let you
breathe so I'm pretty sure all of our
backs are going to be just caked in
sweat a little bit okay though you know
thank you gotta say guys you're giving
me permission to take off my clothes
throughout this through yeah well I'm
not I'd no one has to give you
permission to do that you shouldn't do
that [ __ ] anybody Miller all right so
ladies and gentlemen you're here on
gamespot com / III I guarantee I take
off my shirt by the end of the stream it
tightens last day I'll just be shirtless
good I it's time to talk about all these
press conference it's Tuesday we've seen
all the press conferences now they're
all done where do we want to start of
course over on youtube com such kind of
funny games we have our little wrap ups
of yeah one do you want to start with
the ones we didn't get to do like we
asked where just happened did you guys
get over the chance to wash square yeah
we're not wall enough informed about
square I feel like if it pleases you
uh-huh you should be this is the lady we
should go sequentially okay okay okay
because we didn't c square so we can't
really talk exactly see I was gonna do a
little differently okay the Drake
mentality have started from the bottom
now we here start with the worst one
thing you want to talk about EA yes
there we go but I like your sequential
thing that makes a little bit more sense
cuz i don't wanna be talking [ __ ] we
don't have a twenty talk [ __ ] yeah it's
a little less judgmental oh yes I'm
sorry are those things gonna be in my
peripheral vision the entire time the
tare weight their leadership
envelopes eyota and whoever yeah
probably i would like to get one on
camera great point how can we do that we
have to figure that we can get about the
stage no we're gonna get them on camera
in like five we got a rolling camera
good okay would you have a roaming
camera we got wrong together we wanted
to that can be cool he would love to not
do the others moving the camera cab yeah
yeah okay move uh Kevin also great job a
little bit of feedback on this section I
believe you were supposed to be taking a
break at a 30 minutes in it's not a
problem just make sure you pad for the
extra five minutes good everyone 10
minutes behind correct if Kiki going so
on just this one and then the next hour
I'm gonna be over more importantly
attending like you're throwing to me we
oh my god there's no Nick you get your
free Nick go go go go Nick haha kind of
funny really tearaway guys we're coming
to put you on camera tearaway guys
you're on camera dance with Nick funny
everybody you guys still hear me oh
please the wrong I'm just gonna hear the
rest of the day raw we kick wherever we
kick the deck Greg and here I go can you
still see me Greg can't you hear me Greg
see you I'm in PlayStation just past the
guy who made adventures of him you have
a bath areas God ambition just leave
that up all day long that's a gif I need
everyone to put artists somebody not
calm / forums here you come Thank You
Tara way guys thank you sorry than like
your game oh please ensure i used to say
that room so he need to say because the
internet already knows internet knows
everything yeah alright so it never
forget if we're starting from the bottom
and going up as we go no let's go
chronologically huh nope i lobster
you're not let me know what's up [ __ ]
now there's a lot happening you're not
listening closely enough and you can
someone saying something in your ears so
for everyone out there kevin is talking
into Gracie night right now with the
little ifb it's this whole fancy new
technology it's crazy you know I've
never really useful before I would be
the same way cuz Greg's like when
someone's talking drugs like Greg sees a
long time I use them all the time it's
the promise this one isn't formed in my
ear yeah
it keeps crawling out and coming back on
in that after what you did uh when you
did up at noon you use one no no San
Diego Comic Cons and stuff like that
okay I'm Greg Miller I've done this
before as I like cried because I we've
hosted things together Greg for
literally thousands of hours yeah well
usually when you and I were together at
some little thing they throw us the
scraps no more so i'm saying what i'm
saying is that we've done it for you
know so long and i know your your tix
and your tendencies and I feel like I'm
seeing unique things out of you today
already you know Lori promote your
growing yeah you bet I was good he's
tired look I library made it seem like
it was so far away and you just had to
run back over here like it was like
what's a good half mile mile mile and a
half yeah yeah you ready look like
nothing also I want you guys to know I
made the command decision to move the
stairs from over here yeah to over there
for safety okay and every single person
so far has just jumped off of this out
of the stage into the crowd the vast
crowd that we have there's millions
really whoo whoo we're lucky juicebox
didn't do a flip off the stage I don't I
want to see him do a flip but not on
anybody yeah I do but we have a Romy
camera oh we do have the Roman camera
that should be the so take him into like
III where wherever if he gets hurt
somewhere he gets hurt on III property
yeah in the word on why are obviously
take him through that whole day but it's
not even open anywhere the hall where
like where games went to die oh yeah
yeah whatever anything oh my god they
still use that like it's a good I do you
like to step back a lot cuz we've all
it's all weird tether ething Bethesda
let's actually talk about video games ok
I'll vs. Craigh na dun day night
Bethesda Colin how was it it was awesome
it was a great way to start it went
about how we predicted would ya three
big games right yeah fallout obviously
dishonored and then doom yeah actually
shown in the exact opposite order that I
mentioned them we knew that I felt bad
for arcane specifically that their game
leaked literally like at zero hour so it
wasn't a surprise but fallout 4
obviously arguably the game of the show
I would say yeah it's on the list we
have the blue blue building out ah yeah
well hold it for you if you'd like now
I'm gonna put it in front of my face
under kevin has yelled at us that we
need to go back and make them all black
not yelled at us he's trying to make a
show better I mean a race
are you fine you can talk to rid but
Colin's got fallout 4 at one I've got
fallout 4 at one Tim does it connect the
monster now and Cisco doesn't cuz he's
also a monitor hey does you act dick
doesn't either Nick only is played axiom
verge yeah ok again none of you guys
have played this we don't need to play
fallout 4 to know it's gonna be game of
the show what if you want to close i'll
bring to you there you go now Nick how
did I do it drawing the smiley face I
feel pretty good about that terrible I
don't think that's a fair assessment of
my skills it was poor poor is all right
i'll give you a poll I mean it looks so
it looks like a full smiley face but
something went wrong with haha and
that's like the portillo of our low oh
right I don't think I need a dog into
the baby came out of the womb with a
smile on the side of the head it doesn't
look like a smirk another word sure sure
sure so with that stuff I liked it i
enjoyed it as somebody that those games
aren't tailored toward me but I get it
I'm like my god fallout 4 looks amazing
and that is I'd be shocked if it doesn't
win game of the show for a lot of people
I want to be shocked if it doesn't win
game of the year probably ya know I
guess I i I've talked about it right for
game of the year when i get serious i
only put the games i've played and
that's why of course metal gear solid
right now the top i played two days of
it it's amazing i can't wait to play the
final product uh-huh ah below that was
witcher because we played it but now you
start talking about Batman next week you
start talking about fallout 4 that ever
the Batman he's the goddamn batman be
the Batman Greg beat the Batman be the
Batman oh yeah I think fought for like
the store is this entire show it belongs
to fallout 4 so no no really Final
Fantasy 7 remake I'm gonna stick to that
I big I saw Collins face now granted the
fallout 4 News dropped a while back that
that's premiering sunday feels like
sunday feels like i'm talking about when
they actually announced that fallout 4
oh when we take trailer i would say that
was when you guys were most excited
about fallout 4 I felt like the
conference was just okay it's an actual
real thing or official having said that
when we saw cloud and the dude with the
machine gun arm Barrett Barrett Collins
face looks like he was 12 years old
again he did that that very the very
rarest of smiles that Colin gives the
ear to ear smile yeah
not actually screwing with Collins never
happy well he gives it to you as
sometimes but he went screwing with you
yeah um but he smiled from ear to ear
and looked at me and was like this is
unbelievable like I can't believe this
is happening and to which I replied I
don't understand what this is is this
Final Fantasy 50 don't know what you
know is this fun is a remake of Final
Fantasy 11 oh no not a remake a favorite
everyone watch on favorite is final
fantasy level followed by final fantasy
14 and then four and then but then after
that he starts going into spirits within
which wasn't even if y'all spirits
within the best final fantasy period
naila Wow I hate you so much even though
you weren't a into the bethesda games
you enjoyed the conference you're seeing
how important it was conference was
great like i was a show they did such a
good presentation of that and they made
me understand why fallouts a big thing
you know we did the let's play fallout 3
and i started to get it i saw that
moment when you came out of the vault
you're like whoa there is this whole
world and you were right man seeing it
again involved for I get why that's
special to everybody even though it
didn't resonate with me because I don't
have that experience I understand the
experience that other people get from
that and you guys are going to play that
game for years yeah it's gonna be a
thing it's like what the way we feel
that Witcher 3 right now which is just
it's not a game i'm playing it's
actually a lifestyle choice yeah right
you ignore everything else just to do
that so i can erase all the question
marks for my map yeah excessively one by
one and you look at the legend that it
says question marks 117 you can then
three hours later it's like question
marks 112 like all right again somewhere
now so then moving on Microsoft what do
we hang a Microsoft oh they killed it
now very impressive such a good
conference yes me they always they seem
to be the most well paced of conferences
right we're like I think there was a
time about it was one or two years ago
maybe let's play us like about five
years ago they decided to just show
games and not talk about the stock stuff
and how everyone was doing member that
one that when that changed yeah in the
industry people were like oh right we
need to make these media more fun yeah
we don't we need to go out there and
talk about Q for a cute q 44 q for
stocks or profit margins um what the
hell am I talking about
he is shining through yeah the sunny
degree I got online they seem to be the
ones that kind of get out of how to
perform for the mainstream audiences
right yeah Sony still feels a little
like it lacks and they just show you
stuff sometimes they're not really
explaining context then it's endo to go
straight into that like the ten toes
like you're just showing me and granted
I don't understand what I've translated
yeah trailers with with Japanese little
girl oh I knew it scourge that fire
emblem Shin Megami game and I'm like
okay so what's a call it's a see foot I
CFE and there's a lot of Japanese things
what yeah but whatever but but I like I
always like Microsoft because I feel
like they're better at being at the
showmanship of it they have the better
they always have the edgy or set right
like my sony always does the sort of
panoramic screen which is awesome and
you were you were commenting on your
like that's got to be some sort of at
least an O Maj to Morpheus I thought I'm
the Grand I missed that on a boat on
that PlayStation thing like you weren't
wrong though because if you looked at
the design of that someone looked and
said got inspired by that 360 yeah glass
now they've been doing it for a while
but it had the angular look and heady
angle of like your glasses like what you
have back here glasses and that's why I
was so sure when they went there was
this moment and we're just jumping
around yeah chronological order all
right there was this moment when they
showed the gorilla game and I just give
the award to Horizon when they showed it
and they was in widescreen and then they
expanded decides to fill the entire
thing and I poked Colin because that's
what I was like here it comes they're
gonna say it's a Morpheus game and you
put it on your wrapped in it and then
they didn't and that's when I started
going oh my god all of these are going
to be Morpheus games if they're going to
do something wrong and everything you
see this playable on Morpheus and then
they did that in don't and never have in
it and they talked about Morpheus for
two minutes and 20 seconds yeah and I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
you know it's interesting you say about
the showmanship cuz ya xboxes stage is
definitely I think a level beyond the
Sony said all that stuff so mean nothing
no sony when i get lucky the luck so
Sony had the you know the big screen
which is always beautiful but the thing
that xbox doesn't have is that character
you know Nintendo has Reggie and has
Miyamoto and has all that true and then
you know Sony that house
it has like a voice yeah and these
characters that people know from Twitter
and from just the internet you know just
from years of doing this xbox they have
those guys they're selling their infancy
ya know Spencer is going to be Shuhei
like you but he's building that right
now right yep yeah it's just but right
now without that well does make the no
one will ever be shoe hey sorry
everybody ignore it will ever be sure
hate your seat Shuhei if we hear me the
playstation booth we love you that guy
loves you way too yeah I feel like
that's what xbox is kind of lacking
right now in terms of the press
conference but right besides that oh my
god pacing of the show the games are now
yeah they knocked it out and the
backwards compatibility which I thought
was razy a huge announcement bacon and
uh both Nintendo and Sony lacks that
here's something that's not a game but
it's more of an ecosystem thing to make
your lives better and I expected
everyone to so I'm a little shocked that
it was only Microsoft but they did great
with it yeah so surprising about
Microsoft's thing is compared to Sony is
that Sony usually is the people who are
coming out announcing goods and services
right and I really feel like Microsoft
took that ran with it this year they did
that they had hollow ends and like the
before this like I've used Morpheus when
he pointed at a bar blot oh yeah Adam
what up I Gia's Adam hey and ichante
guys talking to us weird uh before that
is not weird know they've all been
coming over and saying hi today before
that like I had used Morpheus I thought
that's cool i've used oculus i thought
that's cool but then to actually see the
hollow lens in action and to see how it
would play with minecraft and how it
could change again or delete to see half
of it at first every single person that
was watching that was like what the SH
what is this right you're watching guy
play something pretty acted on a wall
yeah hard is that look boom I did it
it's done then he walks over to that
weird crate I beautifully made crate and
boom it comes to life that's when I
think everyone was blown away by that's
when I was like oh yeah yeah yeah the
game he can move in pinch and zoom that
was when it was minority part of course
is very very Tony just I forgot so and
you guys kind of brought this up yes sir
when we were talking about the
conference's but that was the moment
that's being written up by the general
press not just that day that's your USA
Today and that's very important and I
saw that like all the big sites Mashable
and all that that was the headline was
oh my god minecraft
blew everyone away without even really
creating this crazy new game it's just
with what you have it's like all right
they show they showed a gimmicky kind of
piece of tech I gotta say that you know
game of the show goes to Henry Ford the
third hand before the third showing up
with idea things need to be able to land
is what they did oh no I think Pele
definitely should do you think that he
has taught you know what Ryan facing the
rewards Jason guru from Ubisoft yeah
Jason listen I don't understand what
were you saying Nicholas my question is
if you are Henry Ford the third are you
allowed to drive any other car other
than a 40 definitely not and here's the
here's the baby gates not gonna took
that caught in the Toyota right oh shiz
just line right order i really dont wat
anywhere near detroit boy but uh here's
the funny thing is that a lot of the
guys that show off you know you know
Peter Moore for instance mixes his
rounds right and then he's here for
three days and then he goes back to you
know redwood and and and goes to his
office and does his thing a TA but when
i was i love the visual of Henry Ford
the third because Henry the floor of the
third has really no business at e3 right
and I mean that like he could be here he
wants I mean he has no literal business
here yeah so he got on a plane in
detroit came to LA was on a stage said
two things and then got back on a plate
I went back to Detroit probably later
that I released row you drunk you
definitely drove even looking that GT if
the real goes the crew but you hear
something about Microsoft's convert I
think its first of all I was really
blown away by microsoft's press comments
how good it was and I said that which is
why I was impressed I think Sony edged
the mouth because I think Sony had good
good game like really good games to show
you but I do think the biggest and most
significant announcement is the
backwards compatibility on xbox water
that opens up if they want to a thousand
games Xbox my way and that is so they're
starting with 100 and after you know
they have to do it manually they're
basically emulating these games so they
have to get permission from the
publishers and the stakeholders but that
was a significant step because why was
significant was they were like we don't
know and don't think we can do this yeah
we tried to do it and we made it happen
and I think that puts PlayStation on
notice that they need to do the same
thing and they took a shot directly a
Playstation and PlayStation now by
saying we're not going to make you pay
for the games you are my own I 15 show
they also announced that multiplayer
works to right which I'm there was a lot
of question about that so that is really
interesting the thing that worries me it
was a big huge announcement but what
worries me is they did the same thing
with the 360 with which was backwards
compatible with xbox games and it was
this whole like you have to download the
updates
yeah and they did the thing that I hate
that game developers do we're like
Nintendo with this virtual console it's
like why isn't everything just available
now you know like they trickle it out
and all this stuff and I would love to
see where we're at in six months of how
many xbox 360 games are actually
compatible yeah they make it sound like
it's going to be everything PlayStation
now made it sound like it was going to
be every yet it's just that when they
say things like this and it's the same
thing I think it 10 toes a little more
deliberate with why they did it that
family but it really is like they
probably do have to go to with each
individual game and be like this is this
is the source code this is the game that
exist on xbox live this is now Xbox one
reads it it downloads if your xbox one
they promised to do it really game by
game by game and they're doing it
themselves yeah so you assume that if
they could turn it flip a switch it
would make more sense if they could have
said like hey guys every xbox 360 game
is now available on Xbox one that would
have been the headline but that isn't
isn't the case they're starting with 100
by holiday season I think of then
they'll go from that right yeah i was
talking to nathan yesterday when because
he was watching the show with us david
Bella yeah and he I was like I made an
off you know a typical Nick comment not
really understanding the industry and
I'm like that's just a marketing ploy
they could have done this years ago and
he's like a year ago rather and he's
like no it's actually really really hard
cuz you have to when you're developing
you have to do it / platform so for the
Unreal Engine versus a different engine
like there's a whole other ball of wax
and yeah oh so there are actually
technical strains he's like yeah they're
not kidding about that they're serious
like it's really hard to do that yeah
it's even harder apparently i guess for
the ps4 ps3 because the difference in
process oh yeah I diamala to get off
that cell processor that was the thing
and that's what like when certain came
out of the PlayStation 4 launch event he
said to everybody like here's what's
under the hood he was saying we're sorry
it was so hard to program for they were
very clear that if you have a game that
runs on a PC you can bring it over here
without issue that was that me like hey
we know this was everyone's biggest
complaint and that was great moving
forward but it totally does screw things
up going yeah because they would have to
put the Cell processor or figure out a
way to emulate those games on ps4 and I
feel I feel like that might happen it's
unfortunate see the reason that was
significant is it and it was a shot at
Sony was because at a clear shot at
Sony's because sony has siloed off all
of its games on Vita you can play video
games some PSP games some psone classics
you can't play ps2 classics on ps3 you
can play playstation PR PSP minis you
cannot play PSP games you can play ps1
games you play against three games on
ps4 you can play only PS
four games you buy whatever you never
know where it can play hookie to your
boy / back up your feet into the ps4 you
can play it on ps3 you can play it on a
PSP without the Vita yet not here I
think you're getting more up yeah is
that if you're an interrupt though so
that's that's what they're saying I
think that's what they were doing is
like you know unifying the platform
makes a lot of sense in Windows 10
obviously it's a significant step to
that too since the idea of Windows 10 is
to run on everything so that was that
was significant not only because of the
announcement backwards compatibility and
opening up a huge swath of great games
and xbox 360 had significant a
significant library one of the great lab
risen all time it's but it's also you
know we're listening we're updating this
console and that was the difference
between xbox and playstation playstation
talk about games and I think PlayStation
1 with games in the future I think next
box ones with games imminently the
following very bad for PlayStation 4 in
terms of exclusives meanwhile on
Microsoft they have halo they're going
to have gears one remade they're going
to have forza and they're gonna have
rise of the Tomb Raider that significant
exclusive showing on xbox one yeah well
PlayStation 4 right now only has the
Uncharted collection which cancels out
maybe Gears of War which means you
definitely have you have three other
huge games they have to have something
else it might be no man's sky but other
than that mm-hmm you know who the hell
knows and that was that was what I took
away from Microsoft but what's wrong
Greg I want to see you schedule yeah but
but Sony but with Sony I feel like they
just had a more impressive showing an
eight and they came out swinging and
that was when they opened with the Last
Guardian that's a signet that's a game
you would put blast yeah and they and
they're like no we're gonna be good i'm
not i'm not a huge obviously Last
Guardian fanner or I co fan was that
what you wanted it to be when I saw that
ya know personally I don't want you we
want it to be out and we wanted to talk
right here this fall sorry for making
you wait here it is but to me that was
the one fall in 7 2016 right yeah I
wanted that this year release was it a
date would have been [ __ ] perfect but
what I did like that they did is it
wasn't a new game it wasn't like here's
a bunch of new features and here's new
stuff it was the same thing we've seen
before so it's like you were getting the
game that we've waited for and yeah
excites me because I was worried that
they would change things up and I'm
happy they didn't like this is the game
we waited years for it's a reimagining I
saw some comments today of people saying
well it looks like a ps3 game and I'm
like I think you're out of your mind ya
know it doesn't look like a ps3 game at
all it looks like an early ps4 game it
looks like it
has been in development for a long time
because it has the pre-pro and on the
drawing board then developed for eight
or nine years so obviously they rebuilt
it yeah it's a playstation 4 you in
clear well you're seeing that when
people say that is the fact that they
remember the last guardian looking like
that it did look like that but for sure
like when you play super mario 64 and
they put out there you know redone
version like oh it looks the same and
then you go back and look at the
original Super Mario oh no if you go
back and watch those trailers side to
side you're gonna see a stark difference
but in your mind's eye you see I yo good
old bird dog still looking the same it's
like fallout 3 and 4 members like this
looks like fallout 3 i'm like a you know
great dazhe young little i think the
sony's conference last night it's gonna
go down as one of the best e3 press
conferences ever like there was so many
big announcement since there's so many
big games like starting it with Last
Guardian ending it with uncharted for
Shenmue 3 and final fantasy 7 in the
middle of that se7 wasn't even like bomb
drop at the end it was just in the
middle right right right right right i
can't believe that like that's nuts to
me and there was so much other stuff
horizon a new IP that looks awesome
everyone in the room when that demo was
on was impressed by that and was like I
want to place I'm into this you're not
losing me cuz every once in while demos
will come on and you see I i I'm gonna
go pee now you know I do something right
now it's like no like that Sony I think
consistently had the most people in tune
with what was going on like watching the
entire demos yeah I mean what I tweeted
during the conference during the height
of the conference last night that I was
like microsoft conference was awesome
and I think Sony's beating the [ __ ] out
of them right now and realize yeah and
as I got as I got through the rest of
the conference I'm like and I tweeted
out later I'm like that was a little
premature I think so anyone yeah what
because there was a wall and a bail on
the mill but don't you have to take a
point away for the fact that yes they
showed the Last Guardian but everyone
has been the reason that has such an
impact is because of the heritage of
that game not being out not being shown
constantly being kind of dangled in
front of you and everyone's like oh it's
finally here and but like let's not
forget that mom wasn't here for the last
three years right now mom watch the door
with gifts and we're all happy it's been
it's it's true it's been six years since
we saw it yeah and that's a significant
portion of time the game was supposed to
about five years ago so just showing and
being like and being like I would have
liked a different presentation where it
was dated I was surprised that they
and it wasn't this for albeit an
uncharted got pushed you know the first
party ecosystem works in tandem so when
the Charter got push I'm like the last
Guardians gonna be the fall game yeah
they have to be comfortable putting it
putting it pushing that out yet even
though no I don't probably whatever they
want yeah that they have to have this
opening I was like the last card they'll
shown at e3 and they'll dated October
mm-hmm and that didn't happen and I was
shocked that actually they showed it and
it still says 2016 but uh I feel like
that might have been a mistake in a
tactical error too because now
everyone's good what if it doesn't come
out 2016 you know like it has to man it
has to come out 2016 to me like they
should have just waited until Paris
games week or something and been like
all right yeah now we were confident
it's gonna come out and four months or
whatever yes true I think it had to be
at e3 though I really think that that's
the type of game that like they needed
to put it out there and like you know as
much as we needed that date i think that
the general the general public that
scares like it that just knowing that it
still exists i think is important again
be pure sure to get them to know hey you
should buy ps4 for next year like
there's gonna be a good reason and
because there's gonna be a lot of people
that are like should i sell my ps4
should i buy a xbox one xbox a solid
game that down but i feel like they had
that unlock already with uncharted you
don't I mean like they already had your
reason to wait what it is it is the
waiting game and trying to make people
go and continue to buy and care about
the playstation 4 is there but yeah I
don't know if you need to do it yeah I
think and that's the major difference
between Microsoft and Sony and why I
think sony has a lots of fear with
Microsoft moving forward because
Microsoft starting to become in my mind
with under phil spencer quite genius
because they came out beforehand they're
like we have beat three big exclusives
that we're not even to talk about right
there like scalebound is not going to be
here crackdowns not going to be here
quantum break which is a really huge
exclusive is it going to be here and
instead what they focus on was imminent
games and then they had a game like in a
phone a's game react recording stuff but
they were like we have four big games
coming out this fall and here the four
big games plus we're going to butcher
sit with gears for which looks awesome
and then we're going to have a few other
things in the middle so and what's scary
for what should be scary for sony is
that a games come then there in august
then so microsoft's gonna be well now
we're gonna talk about twenty sixteen
games yeah and here's crackdown and
here's quantum bro yeah there's a scale
down and meanwhile sony will have twenty
sixteen games you assume a game while
obviously the last guardian
horizon which has been a development for
four years Hakeem's but Sony's Sony's I
doesn't seem to be on the ball for this
fall and I think it could be a huge
blunder for them because everyone's like
oh you play your third party games I'm
like wait what you're forgetting is your
third party games are available
everywhere yeah you know yeah if you I'm
the shooter guys there's still they
still haven't transferred over to ps4
you know like they they still are home
on xbox one you know and until they get
that that's a lot of the third party
games so yeah I mean it's so the thing
is this ps4 is selling in in spite of a
lot of the developers in the first party
system not being ready yet but in terms
of exclusives unless Sony does something
Microsoft is going to clean Sony's clock
this this from this fall not maybe in
terms of sales necessarily but in terms
of just here's why you should have an
xbox one specifically III and I fear
that Sony might have not kept their eye
on the ball a year or two be like it did
they give them the room right now to
catch up right the end what you're
saying yeah year ago two years ago in
production development timelines did
they give this this opening the window
they clearly assumed I'm charted was
gonna be ready yep yeah this is another
order 1886 fall know they thought this
was going to be there and now it's not
and now there's nothing that's trouble
additionally i'm shorter collections
gonna be great but it's not going to be
plated lad of those game really I like
the part where he stood there for a good
five minutes and just watch that guy
churn butter that's uncharted 4 and that
was a mistake because i was hired where
the guy i mean it was beautifully rent
it was a great render yeah really good
and the fruit vendors play something
other than axe ebert can't I can't I
can't wait shovel Knight I play limbo
for a second how'd that go it's fun yeah
that's why so there we talked we talked
a lot about you know Sony only ever saw
we have one minute left okay was
disappointing it was just what everybody
had big games and a mass effect there's
another thing went bad I'm just saying
it was disrespected the beginning
mirrors edge of the middle of battle
from everything else that mobile sec
yeah but that's like those are huge they
are well with exemptions of adverse edge
but in terms of the performance in terms
of being excited I was like yeah when it
went when we came out and I feel bad for
a while she's starting off with the new
Mass Effect's come on that's bad but
when the woman's like let's talk about
mobile and and in the war room
everyone's like
yeah it was it was it you know he was
awful solid Nintendo today was weird cuz
it was weird I wanted it to be a lot
better and more exciting than it was
yeah but you know at the end of the day
they're gonna have great games this
holiday and I'm that excites me they're
in a holding pattern yeah yeah it's
obvious I didn't get a chance to watch
Ubisoft how did Aisha do I issue as
awesome as I can we start calling it
Aisha Tyler show no we're awesome keep
it here on gamespot com / III